this episode is made possible by tab for
a cause install the free browser
extension and start making a difference
today
if you were asked to picture the earth
what would come to mind
probably the color blue there's a good
reason for that the surface of the earth
is composed of over 70% water 71% to be
precise
which means that humans are left with
29% of the Earth's surface to call their
own
water is an integral part of life on
Earth the world's ocean supports
somewhere between 1 and 10 million
diverse species of plant and animal life
all of which rely on their watery home
to survive and these species in turn
support humans by providing huge
quantities of food to populations around
the world according to current
scientific understanding water is
necessary not only for continued life
but also quite possibly for life to have
begun on earth in the first place with
that in mind what would happen if the
planet's oceans disappeared overnight
the most immediately noticeable change
after the oceans vanished would be the
massive stretches of sunken ground where
water used to be without oceans 71% of
the earth would become an enormous
expanse of canyons these canyons would
be so deep in some places that it would
be the equivalent of looking down at the
ground from the window of a commercial
jet
unfortunately we wouldn't have much time
to admire our new scenery because the
ocean performs several very important
jobs and with all that water gone things
would get very bad very quickly one
factor to consider is that marine plants
produce over 70% of the planet's oxygen
far more than terrestrial trees and
other plants if the ocean suddenly
disappeared all the world's marine
plants would go with them this would not
only drastically reduce the amount of
available oxygen in the atmosphere but
also severely impact the planets ability
to process excess co2 since carbon
dioxide is already one of the main
culprits behind climate change the
massive decrease in co2 processing
ability would contribute greatly to
warming the planet at a much faster rate
besides supporting the majority of
oxygen producing plants and providing
over 3.5 billion people with their
primary source of food the world's
oceans also perform the critical job of
regulating the planet's temperature
large bodies of water like oceans are
very effective means of absorbing and
distributing solar radiation currents
circulate warm water from the tropics to
the north and south and bring cold water
back to the equator distributing heat
energy in a manner
that keeps anyone area from becoming too
hot or too cold to support life the
oceans also allow for the existence of
what we call the water cycle the
movement of water from the ocean to the
clouds often traveling many miles before
falling as rain on land or back into the
ocean like the movement of currents the
water cycle also provides more even heat
distribution without oceans all of this
goes away the Equator would be scorched
into oblivion with rain virtually
non-existent much of the earth would
transform into barren deserts trees
plants and grass would become so dry
that fires would spring up across entire
continents causing countless deaths of
course the fires would also have a
secondary effect without marine plants
to help filter out the huge amounts of
co2 being produced by the worldwide
fires the planets rise in temperature
would continue to accelerate with
greenhouse gases building up and
trapping the sun's rays one study
suggests the planet's average
temperature would creep towards 153
degrees Fahrenheit
forcing entire populations to migrate to
Antarctica the last bastion of livable
temperatures on the entire earth for the
small numbers that managed to make it to
Antarctica
the outlook would still be very bleak as
temperatures around the world rose
humans would have to spend their days
hurriedly constructing underground
shelters and storing ice and water from
glaciers and snow before it melts and
evaporates of course building these
underground bunkers and storehouses
would only be possible if some of the
fleeing humans had the presence of mind
to bring along industrial construction
equipment and huge amounts of supplies
as unlikely as that would be assuming we
did manage to construct an underground
building large enough to support save
several thousand people could we survive
in the long run probably not back on the
surface all plant and animal life will
have been wiped out and the raging fires
will have caused the atmosphere to
become unbreathable to humans with no
way to return to the surface safely and
no way to restart a healthy carbon cycle
all we would be able to do is watch our
supplies slowly dwindle to nothing and
wait for the end
a world without oceans would be
completely unlivable to anything but the
hardiest extrema file bacteria not a
very pleasant thought luckily the oceans
probably aren't going anywhere anytime
soon and certainly not overnight so
we really don't have to worry too much
about an entire world without water that
being said there are many places around
the world where clean drinking water
simply isn't available if you want to
help take two seconds to install the tab
for a cause extension for your web
browser tab for a cause is a browser
extension that donates to a charity of
your choice each time you open a new tab
without costing you a thing just by
browsing the web tab errs have now
raised more than four hundred thousand
dollars for charity through tab for a
Cause installing the extension takes
almost no effort and lets you make a
real difference every single day just by
using your web browser click the link in
the description to start tapping for
your cost today if you enjoyed this
video make sure to watch these next
remember to subscribe to keep up to date
with the latest content and if you're
tired of learning come watch me play
games with a friend on my new gaming
channel thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next video